what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime uproar and today i will be
breaking down the most recent events and
developments
in the boku no hero story including the
absolute
monster that is the new shigeraki
the imminent danger that bakugo and deku
find themselves
in and the desperate attempt by the
heroes to stop
what could be the biggest disaster in
boku no hero
history there is a lot to talk about the
stakes are higher than they have
ever been so let's get into it
if you enjoyed the boku no hero content
on this channel and you'd like us to
keep it going
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you happen to be
new to the channel
or you just haven't subscribed yet
please consider subscribing and hitting
that notification bell to turn on
all notifications if you don't go
through the trouble of clicking the bell
and then selecting the option that says
all you're gonna miss a lot of our
videos even if you're subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
finally this video will of course
contain boku no hero manga spoilers we
are talking about the very latest events
in the story
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned
the latest chapter starts off with the
confirmation that shigaraki has been
able to locate deku using the quirk
search which was stolen from ragdoll it
appears that ragdoll's quirk had
registered one for all's data
before her quirk was stolen by all for
one and so now shigaraki is able to
pinpoint the exact location
and weak points of deku the current user
of one for all
as shigaraki is zeroing in on deku
endeavour
asks what on earth deku is saying and
never doesn't know why shigaraki would
be targeting deku
out of all the people here but deku just
says that he'll explain later
unlike deku and bakugo endeavour doesn't
know the truth about one for all
and its origins so it makes sense that
he wouldn't understand what makes deku
so special it must seem extremely
strange to endeavor that shigaraki would
ignore him
the number one pro hero in order to hunt
down a first-year pro hero high school
student
as shigaraki flops down to the ground
from his massive jump
endeavour sees an opening and attacks
for a moment it looks like shigaki
suffered serious damage as a result of
endeavour's attack
but to endeavour's great surprise
shigaraki just
keeps moving he jumps up again and takes
off and
endeavors simply can't keep up endeavour
uses their wireless communication
system to warn deku that shigaraki is
headed southwest
and deku responds by saying that he will
do his best to buy time for everyone to
evacuate by trying to lure shigaraki
away from the civilians
endeavour then uses the same
communication device to warn everyone
else that shigaraki has changed course
and is now headed south west and he also
warns everyone that shigaraki now
possesses
super regeneration and that he is
completely different from the shigeraki
that they faced before by monitoring
shigaraki's movements and sudden change
of course
endeavour concludes that deku might be
right shigaraki seems to be heading
straight for our boy
midoriya however as we know from the
previous chapter
deku is not alone as deku tries to get
as far away as possible from the
evacuation zone
he is being followed by bakugou knowing
how dangerous shigaraki has become
deku asks bakugou why he is tagging
along
but this sets bakugo off bakugo can't
believe that deku would accuse him
of just tagging along as if deku
was the protagonist and bakugo was just
a support character and i thought that
this moment was both
meta and hilarious at the same time even
though deku is technically the
protagonist of boku no hero
you just know that in his own mind
bakugou is the true protagonist
and so of course bakugou refuses to let
deku have all the attention and all the
glory
after all bakugou still has a score to
settle with shigaraki
bakugo still feels bad about the kamino
incident because his kidnapping by the
villains
is what set off that entire chain of
events a chain of events that
ultimately led to all might's retirement
bakugo still blames himself for this
and he plans to redeem himself right
here and now
bakugo has a plan to take down shigaraki
while using one for all
as bait since shigaraki is completely
focused on one for all
so much so that he is completely
ignoring even the number one pro hero
bakula thinks that he can use this to
his advantage
and take shigaraki down while he is
distracted by his obsession for one for
all
nevertheless i don't think that bakugou
realizes just how insanely overpowered
this new shigaraki is bakugo is
extremely confident
perhaps overly confident and that could
come back to haunt him
taking on this new shigaraki is a
massive risk
clearly even the number one pro hero was
unable to stop shigaraki or contain him
in any way and yet bakugou claims to
have a plan that can stop him
whatever that plan may be it will have
to be absolutely amazing
and it will have to be completely
unexpected by shigaraki himself
i definitely understand bakugo's
motivation i can see where he's coming
from he is a strong and powerful guy who
has a score to settle with shigaraki
and he is also the guy who has always
been able to keep up with deku no matter
how much stronger deku became and no
matter how quickly he improved after
inheriting one for all
bakugou has also been training extra
hard in order to keep
up with deku and he has been pretty
successful so far
so bakugo believes that he can keep that
streak going he can surpass his limits
just like dekku and take his strength
and ability
to the next level but even if bakugo can
surpass his limits and reach the next
level of power
is that enough to defeat shigaraki in
his current
insanely overpowered state as much as i
understand where bakulo is coming from
i don't think he stands a chance against
the new shigaraki
the only way that any of them could
stand a chance against shigaraki now
is if they are able to use some
absolutely incredible
teamwork teamwork that involves multiple
overpowered heroes
and hero students all working together
and using their various unique quirks
to their advantage but while deco and
bakugou are trying to lure shiguraki
away from the evacuation zone
shigaraki is quickly gaining full
mastery of
all for one he easily combines two
different quirks in order to jam the
hero's electronic communication
system and as shigaraki is effectively
combining quirks that all for one had
stolen
deku has the same feeling that he felt
back in kamino when he first encountered
all for one himself this new shigaraki
is already at that level and perhaps
even stronger
and this is a terrifying thought as
overpowered as oliver one was during the
kamino incident
he was also old and injured but
shigaraki is something else
altogether and ujiko certainly believed
that shigaraki has surpassed
all for one's potential so that is
something that we have to keep in mind
as shigaraki prepares to acquire one for
all and destroy deku
we see images of deku's and bakugou's
faces
beginning to decay in these images it
looks like both deku and bakugou are
literally about to die
and you can just imagine how freaked out
people were when they first saw the
leaks
of this chapter seeing these images
without context could absolutely make
you think that bakugou and deku are
goners
here it looks like they're already in
the process of being decayed
a process that could be irreversible but
in
reality before shigaraki actually
reaches deku and bakugo
they are rescued by gran torino the
extremely fast gran torino grabs them
and rushes them out of shiraki's path
and then he tells them that they just
can't fight this new shigaraki alone
gran torino warns them that shigaraki's
decay will destroy
anything it touches and even just
brushing up against some of the falling
debris
will cause decay to spread all over
their bodies
gran torino was able to arrive just in
time because he heard that one for all
was mentioned
and he instantly knew that this would be
shigaraki's next
target but he tells deku and bakugo
straight up
that in their current state they cannot
even hope
to defeat shigaraki even deku our
protagonist
the inheritor of one for all and someone
who has improved immensely
over the course of the series is still
no match
for the new shigaraki however gran
torino assures the two hero students
that there are heroes
still standing and shigaraki cannot beat
everyone
just as i was saying earlier on in the
video deckwood bakugou are not enough to
defeat shigaraki even the number one pro
hero
just isn't enough on his own but if a
bunch of these
overpowered heroes and hero students
work together
if they can strategically combine their
various quirks and other abilities
then they might stand a chance
especially if shigaraki is distracted by
his obsession for acquiring one for all
in that moment ryukyu in her dragon form
jumps out at shigaraki and slashes at
him with one of her arms
shigaraki places his hand on the uq's
giant dragon arm in order to decay it
but he appears to have failed then up on
a hill and
in the distance we see our boy
eraserhead
it appears that the uq was saved from
destruction because eraserhead was using
his quirk to block shigaraki from using
his own quirks
as shigaraki fails to the ground as a
result of the uq's blow
eraser had vows to avenge crust and his
friend
oburo and he also tells shigaraki not to
mess
with his students this is such a great
moment for our boy
izawa this dude who on normal days is
just like a sleepy and unkempt high
school teacher
is in this very moment a fierce and
unflinching pro hero
who is preparing to defend his students
at all cost
and as badass as eraserhead looks in
this moment and he definitely looks
totally badass
the final panel of the chapter shows
shigaraki's face
and shigaraki does not appear to be
worried by this
turn of events man a lot has happened in
this one chapter
and a lot more is about to happen in the
coming chapters
we now know for sure that despite being
completely new to using all for one
shigeru appears to have an innate
instinct for using
all of these different quirks in just
the right way his ability to combine
two separate quirks in order to jam the
hero's communications
proves that he is already an expert at
using all for one
there is no learning curve for shigaraki
he seems to have
instantly mastered all of all for one's
abilities and that is really bad news
for the heroes the fact that shigaraki
was able to withstand endeavour's
attacks without breaking a sweat
and the fact that endeavour was unable
to impede shigaraki's progress towards
deku
is also very bad news for the heroes
gran torino clearly realized the gravity
of the situation
because he rushed over to deku and
bakugo he moved them out of shigaraki's
path
and he warned them that even though they
have protagonist powers
even they cannot hope to defeat the new
shigaraki
but the somewhat good news for the
heroes is the fact that a bunch of them
managed to survive the destruction
at the hospital including endeavour
ryukyu gran torino and of course
eraserhead our bunny queen miruko
survived as well but unfortunately she
is no longer in
fighting shape nonetheless the fact that
a bunch of strong heroes did survive
means that they can now all work
together and combine their quirks in an
attempt to defeat shigaraki
the fact that eraser had survived is
especially important
his unique ability to block the effects
of quirks could be the only thing that
saves the heroes from shigaraki's
incredible power
a power that now includes the ability to
use who knows how many overpowered
quirks at the same time
but even though the heroes have been
able to regroup we can't forget
that their time is limited as we know
shigaraki is not the only threat to the
heroes even though he is the most
shockingly overpowered one other strong
villains
including gigantomachia and toga
are on their way to the battlefield so
if the heroes cannot defeat shigaraki
quickly
they are going to have a lot more on
their plate
very soon so not only do the heroes and
hero students have to find a way to stop
the completely broken
awakened shigaraki but they have to do
it soon
very soon i am absolutely stoked to see
how this incredible arc
is unfolding and i'm extremely impressed
by how horikoshi has been able to
structure this arc
and how everything is now coming
together in one epic
uber showdown a showdown between the
strongest heroes and hero students
and the strongest villains please let me
know what you guys think do you believe
that the heroes and hero students can
come up with some sort of brilliant team
strategy to neutralize and defeat
shigaraki
however i will say that if you think
that eraserhead
is the silver bullet and that he can
solve all of the hero's problems
i wouldn't be so sure as soon as
shigaraki figures out what's going on
he can find a way to escape eraserhead's
line of sight
just like the female nomu did back at
the hospital and as soon as he does that
he'll be able to use his quirk again
and since eraserhead is currently
located pretty far away from shigaraki
it shouldn't be too hard for shiguraki
to hide behind something
and escape eraserhead's gates so
will the heroes get the job done before
gigantomachia
dobby and the others arrive and if they
don't
get the job done if they can't defeat
shigaraki
what do you think will happen do the
heroes even stand a chance against
all of these overpowered villains or are
the heroes finally heading for a
decisive defeat
such a high profile defeat for the
heroes would completely destabilize the
entire hero
society everyone would panic and
absolute chaos would ensue
if you think the kamino incident was bad
don't forget that that was a battle that
the heroes
ultimately won if the heroes actually
lose here
if the number one pro hero loses the
confidence that the general population
has in the heroes
will shatter trust in the hero society
would collapse
and things would never be the same again
and that is exactly what the villains
want finally what was the deal with
those images of deku and bakugou being
decayed
was that like a premonition was it
shigaraki using some sort of quirk that
projects a vision of their own
deaths onto his opponents or was it
something else altogether let me know
what you think down in the comments
below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more please leave a like to let
me know it really does help and if you
happen to be new to anime pro or you
just haven't subscribed yet
i ask you to please consider subscribing
and hitting that notification bell to
turn on
all notifications remember that you
really have to go through the trouble of
clicking that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all it's annoying i know
but if you don't do that you're gonna
miss a lot of our videos even if you are
subscribed
it's just how youtube works feel free to
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for making
videos like this one possible
a very special thank you to a friend a
a disciple of lord twigo himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata
alolan adam the world steelers acquired
respect
pate heffa jonathan king decided brandon
aviles papa smurf the school bus
king riser emperor otaku richie martinez
and thomas
jones and of course another big thank
you to all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan jason wilson
kings eldris anatoly kazatsky angel cruz
cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci alicia ochter
jessica kayla fond hinokamien water
bonnie parks zodiar12 rathuindeora
emperor
cynical kraken fulgaz 77 and
deadly saint if you enjoy our videos and
you feel that they provide value for you
consider supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you